two of the most well-known people in
their respective Industries may be the
next power couple and people especially
the NFL onir Crews cannot stop making
jokes about it there have been heavy
rumors that Taylor Swift and Travis
Kelce are dating how are an inseason NFL
star and the biggest artist in the world
who has been touring the US for the past
year dating I mean I don't know but
there was an absolutely legendary moment
when Travis scored a touchdown this past
Sunday Ian Eagle said on the live
broadcast Kelsey finds a blank space for
the score it didn't stop there either
the on air crew was able to sneak in an
impressive amount of tailor with puns
when talking about Travis's return to
the field Rich Eisen would say how
Kelsey left a blank space on the team's
lineup while he was out how he proves to
be an anti-hero and more Travis then
responded commenting well played Rich
well played Travis's older brother Jason
Kelsey can't even fully deny it either
he said he doesn't really know what's
going on but he does know that Travis is
having fun